hello folks welcome to rational science
you have a good day today great day
today in fact and uh we're gonna be
doing a little bit of space time so like
I say if you have the time I've got the
space
uh when
um also answer some questions at the end
of the uh
uh Victor and uh we're gonna begin with
our Extinction segment as always first
I'm going to deal with this little issue
that uh started a couple weeks ago uh
where I discussed
um our natural diet
and I suggested that you know we have
these canines right uh mammals in
general uh who are carnivores have them
and fellow says the following okay
related today he says man is a great is
a meat eater but canines have nothing to
do with it
gorilla plant eater has the longest
canine of any primate and that's true I
mentioned that the other day Okay and
here it is
uh you can see he's got big fangs there
but so do chimps and they do eat meat
they do kill in fact other
um chimps they cannibalize so
um exactly why gorillas have uh these
big teeth I have no idea uh they're not
carnivores they're primarily
herbivores they do eat termites and tiny
insects apparently uh I don't think
they're into meat per se I don't know if
they can eat meat uh and talking about
gorillas I thought I'd mention this uh
you know they're genetic diversity is
twice as high as that of humans same as
chimpanzees and there's only what about
106 107 000 gorillas in the world most
of them there in those regions of Africa
and we're eight billion and they have
twice as much genetic diversity as us
so keep that in mind okay and my issue
with
animals such as gorillas you know is
that we probably don't need them
on Earth dangerous animals
uh
should we preserve them should we try to
like a lot of these conservationists uh
do they try to
you know see if they can save uh animals
here and there endangered species and uh
all this kind of
um
work that they do
and I I suggest the following uh the
opposite I'm saying we should kill
all dangerous animals
we don't need alligators we don't need
sharks we do not need Lions we do not
need Tigers we don't need any of these
dangerous animals out there bears wolves
we don't need them
and some people say oh but you're going
to upset the Natural Balance
believe me you know when the mastodons
and the uh Woolly Mammoths disappeared
uh nothing the world didn't stop okay we
all kept going and I'm sure that if
today we go into the different countries
of Africa that have a lot of these wild
animals and we wipe them all out
I mean completely we killed the Lions we
killed the hyenas we killed the uh the
uh these dogs that are running around
um uh the wildebeest also the zebras
let's kill them all sharks uh well not
sharks but uh alligators or or
crocodiles whatever
let's kill them all
and I'm sure that if we go in there and
get rid of them and we plant potatoes or
bananas or whatever grows in each of
those countries
uh nothing will happen in other words
the world will not come to a stop
because we killed all the lions by the
way there's only like 20 000 Lions I
found out today uh last count I had 35
000 Lions so lions are dying really fast
okay they're they're on their way out
and the other reason I suggest getting
rid of these animals is that we are
about to become extinct
so we don't need them in our you know in
our last few days of our stay here on
Earth so if if you're into the
extinction Theory and you believe that
um yeah that man is in trouble you know
that we're about to become extinct
um
you know getting rid of all these
animals doesn't do doesn't even tickle
us okay in fact we're doing them a favor
yeah you might say oh you're crazy what
do you mean we're doing there we're
killing them yeah me and it's called
euthanasia you know it's like we don't
wait for them to suffer
uh being the last lonely animals like
you know you had the um uh some animals
out there different animals in different
parts of the world uh when they were the
last ones the last Nando those are an
example it must have been very very
um sad
to see that you know here here's the
last of their species
and the question is why wait for that
day why wait for Lions to whittle down
until there's only 10 or 15 of them you
know lonely animals there
uh I'm not sure we're doing uh that many
harm by getting rid of them today aside
from the fact that they are dangerous
animals why do we need them
and think about that I know people don't
like me saying all that but think about
it for a while for a minute you know do
we need these animals uh would it be
better off if we got rid of them
anyways I did say about the canines that
uh here you have the dog the snake the
shark especially they have big fangs
okay whereas the cow doesn't and so to
answer this fellow uh I would say that
you know uh no we do not
um use these we did not develop I think
the our canines the upper ones for
um
for protection I think we developed them
as carnivores how the gorillas developed
theirs I don't know all I can tell you
is that
um some of these other animals that you
saw there like a hippo and so on their
canines come from the bottom up they
don't have canines coming down so if you
look at them they all have including uh
Rhino you know it's got this horn it's
not a tooth but it's this horn is always
coming upwards those are yes for defense
I was looking at Triceratops also had
this this beak you know coming upwards
and then the horns you know and so so
you know when you look at all this uh
those features I think were for defense
that's very different than an animal
such as a lion any cat for that matter
that has you know the upper ones coming
down you know and I think those are
uh specifically of carnivores and in
fact that's how they determine sometimes
when they find bones in the mountain
um from way back when you know millions
of years ago they look at the teeth and
they say look this animal was a
herbivore and this and the other animal
was a carnivore and they can tell
because of of the teeth or at least
that's that's a good rule of thumb you
know to figure that out
anyways talking about lions here's a
fellow who says uh what he says Minds
have a sense of time which I said last
time you know they wait for the
migrations of some of these other
animals uh could be will there bees
could could be zebras or whatever
um and they have these migrations when
they come around you know the lines know
that uh the my the all these
um
herbivores are coming in their Direction
it's like it's not a watch but it is a
calendar you know it's like they have a
calendar in their brains and so they
have a sense of time they also I say
that you know like a lion has a sense of
timing like when he hides and he waits
to Ambush some kind of prey
um he knows more or less you know
intuitively whether he can catch that
animal or not how fast he is and how
fast the animal is and based on that he
knows when to start to run after it you
know he's not going to run after an
animal that's you know uh a mile away he
doesn't do that he waits for the animal
to approach him and then at some point
you know there's a give and take between
the animal discovering the lion and
running away and the lion have to act
and so at some point he acts runs after
the uh deer or whatever and uh you know
and it's a timing issue they know more
or less whether they can catch that
animal knowing their own speed so they
know how much time they have you know so
I think that animals do have a sense of
time he says are you serious time is a
man-made concept period
what next time dilation remember physics
not Concepts okay well I just have to
Enlighten this uh fellow on something
else and here it is ah if I can get it
get it on the other side
yeah
is it this
give me a second here
and it's this the Circadian uh clock you
know say circadian uh or circadian uh
Rhythm right and then it says clocks in
the eye and the pineal gland of fish
reptiles and birds the eyes of marine
mullers Etc grasshopula you know the uh
fly uh all these have this Circa Cadian
Rhythm and so the question is uh you
know do animals have some kind of clock
and I would say they do you know Bears
know that at some point in the year they
have to go into the cave you know it's
Winter's coming then they come out in
summer after sleeping it off which is
again a circadium rhythm kind of thing
and so the the issue is yeah animals do
have a sense of time as far as I'm
concerned and you know instead of saying
wow uh you know you gotta show you got
to argue why you think they don't
not just saying oh that's crazy you know
or whatever no answer the question you
know why do you think animals don't have
not all animals probably I don't know
you know I can tell you that some
mammals I think have a sense of time
and maybe a rudimentary one it's not the
seconds and minutes that we have but
they do have a sense an intuitive sense
of timing so I don't think humans are
the only
animals that have discovered time okay
okay uh here we have something that uh
happened uh in the 19th century changing
the subject a little bit and it's the
British and they took over certain parts
of India and Pakistan and Burma and some
of these countries out there
okay uh they went in there and uh looks
like now it's the other way around now
it looks like an Indian Pakistan and
some of these other countries are taking
over
um England over Great Britain you know
here you see uh the new wave of uh
rulers and people who have power in the
United Kingdom and none of them have you
know English sounding names
uh in fact most of them are from either
Pakistan descendants from Pakistan uh
and India so maybe we should change the
flag and put the Indian flag with uh to
Pakistani Flags you know side by side
with a Union Jack there you know maybe
we should get rid of the lion put the
tiger as the mascot you know
because yeah the people who are ruling
Great Britain now are really uh a lot of
them are not
traditional British okay and that's
interesting so I guess it's a reverse
Conquest
uh
United Kingdom conquered
um India Pakistan whole region now these
people are conquering uh Great Britain
okay uh here we had a case a fellow who
apparently went in there and took some
information
and put it on the internet and so the uh
Pentagon and some of the defense uh
group you know and uh intelligent
Services they were a little concerned
about that and they arrested this fellow
the other day and apparently some kind
of gamer I had a little group there
where he shared this information and so
they made a big fuss about that what was
interesting is that I had a similar
feeling to this fellow and he is from
Russia he's one of the ministers over
there and he had the following he says
says U.S intelligence leaks may be a
fake part of a hybrid war against it
against Russia right Russian Deputy
foreign minister Sergey ryabkov said on
Wednesday that a trove of U.S
intelligence documents posted online in
recent weeks might be fake and a
deliberate attempt to mislead Moscow
okay any intelligence agencies do a lot
of that
I can attest testify to that they do
more than steal information they're in
the business of misinforming the other
side I think that's that's more of what
they do uh that's my take on that and so
um you know you have people like Assange
and Ed Snowden you know as far as I'm
concerned those are U.S government
operations they have nothing to do with
spying they're not spying against Russia
they're not spying against China no
they're spying against the American
people okay that's their job they're
they're put there as the leaders of the
United States
um dissidents political dissidents so
that people follow them and say well I
trust this guy because the U.S is
against them and what the guy is feeding
you is what the U.S wants you to
swallow
so that's the way it works so you got to
be careful about all that
sleep with one eye open I can't tell you
that all of them are fakes but certainly
a lot of them are you know the United
States spends 90 billion dollars a year
in intelligence and most of that is to
keep its own people under wraps right
okay here you have uh this situation uh
we have a
America is a fella who went to uh China
is from France he's the president his
name is Emmanuel macron right and uh he
went over there and he started
bad-mouthing the United States more or
less okay uh he said that he's
um he doesn't want uh Europe to become a
vassal to the United States
and that the Europe in general should
reduce its dependence on the U.S dollar
he further added that Europe should
chart a different course from the U.S
with Taiwan
man those who are strong words and uh
this will at least uh from The Daily
Beast uh he said you know has reminded
us that several deep and important
Global friendships of the US have been
sorely tested more worrisome perhaps is
that they may be a a sign of things to
come for us in a world in which we are
no longer the only Global superpower and
our principal rival a global block led
by China
is seeking to build up its own network
of influence so a lot of people had lots
to say about what macron had to say over
there in China you know bad-mouthing the
United States and all that and in fact
one of them uh said the following and
this was a German Minister said this
about macra and he says uh the idea of
strategic autonomy of the European Union
I fear is naive meaning uh that Mr
macron Was Naive right Security on
European soil without the Strategic
nuclear potential of the United States
at least is Unthinkable that U.S and
Europe are partners and values and
should also be trading partners the
Finance Minister added alluding to the
ongoing negotiations between the Biden
Administration and the EU regarding the
inflation reduction act a subsidy
program which favors investment in the
U.S drawing them away from Europe
so uh you know he gave his little uh
kick to the U.S saying uh you know
you're subsidizing your own industry but
we agree with you uh macron is is you
know out of line saying that Europe
should distance itself a little bit from
the U.S and then Taiwan is not Europe's
business etc etc
where you know again I I doubt that Mr
macron uh uh
really believes that or said that uh
uh you know in an honest way okay so
this is my take on end here it is uh
this um uh analysis
um he went to the macro and went to
China for what he went to sell airplanes
that's why he went there for it he
didn't go there to talk about Taiwan he
didn't go to talk about bad mouth the
U.S that was all politics what he went
there is to sell airplanes okay and
that's what the main discussion was well
after they had their talks what was the
result well it says new no new airplane
orders were announced during the visit
China said well we'll see
okay and I think that's the main reason
he went there and just to rub it in
here's uh what one of his macarons
ministers said okay this how politics is
really done okay it says Lemire you know
he's the Finance Minister tell reporters
that there was a strong coordination
between Paris and Washington under
positions on China ahead of President
Emmanuel macron's recent visit to the
country
yeah so uh I think that's that's the
real thing there you know uh can you
imagine if macron would have gone to
China without consulting or talking with
the US first or putting them on notice
first saying look we're going to try to
sell some airplanes so I hope you don't
mind but we're gonna badmouth you we're
gonna say everything that we can against
you that we're allowed to you know like
we should distance ourselves a little
bit from you in taiwan's not our problem
and the US said okay we understand you
want to sell some airplanes and you
gotta lie a little okay no biggie and
that's why Biden the Biden
Administration I think said very little
about macron
and the people who really jumped up uh
were the other the Republicans who said
oh look what macro insane you know no no
he went there to sell some airplanes
that's what he went there for he didn't
do very well with that uh so he had come
to come back to France uh with his tail
between his legs Chinese said well we'll
see if we buy more airplanes okay but uh
yeah I imagine if macron would have gone
in there and said you know we hate all
you Chinese and we think Taiwan should
be a separate country and all this and
that said and by the way do you want to
buy our airplanes
I don't think it works that way no no he
had the bad mouth the United States put
a little distance between it and uh
France so that maybe maybe the Chinese
would warm up to his airplanes that's
how politics really done that's why I
gotten away from party
okay uh how is the world doing well
here's the IMs five-year growth forecast
is the weakest since 1990 for the world
you know for the entire planet okay and
set the IMF forecast that global economy
will grow at a seasonal uh around three
percent annually over the next five
years
not a very strong number okay and again
I'm saying that the entire planet is
getting into this asymptotic growth
Trend okay its weakest medium term
projection since 1990 and then there's
the managing director of the IMF cited
geopolitical Factor stubbornly High
inflation and recent banking industry
pressures for the lukewarm Outlook and
it wasn't only the IMF we had the World
Bank also and this is what they predict
and you can see that most of the
countries are in the dark
uh the ones that are in in the uh bright
uh are countries that are in the
developing stage so of course you know
they're gonna suffer some
um
uh increases some big increases in their
economies in the next maybe months or
maybe a couple years but they're going
to level off as well and just now as you
can see for the global growth it's just
1.7 this year
um numbers are not that great for for
the uh coming years
but the ones that are going to be
driving the global growth are as you can
see all these underdeveloped nations
primarily in Africa and Southeast Asia
but what happens when they
achieve you know uh their maximum
development their maximum economic
evolution
well after that all I can tell you is
that uh you know we cannot have the uh
Klingons coming by from us okay so uh at
that point you know the Earth are the
humans you know the human economy
doesn't grow anymore
um so at some point we're gonna reach
that point where it's zero growth for
the entire planet as far as you know
economic growth so
I'm saying we're getting there and when
we do that's it for man okay we don't go
further beyond that okay so here is
another uh parameter and that is the
um
the debt okay for the fishing for China
and United States and you can see how
that's going uh up and up okay uh they
say dude a few increase I think it's
it's a question of
um you know that they're uh they have to
create money and when they create money
why part of the reason is so that they
can pay what they owe you know and uh
it's easy to create money all you do is
just put another zero in the computer
now you have 10 times as much right
and if we should put it at the end in
front but um what happens when when you
have that situation well all you're
doing is creating money but you haven't
created the real value that underlies
that uh nominal value
and you can't just keep doing that but
they have to do that in order to pay the
debt so they pay the debt in nominal
Value Plus some interest right but they
have to stay ahead of the game all the
time and you can't do that constantly
because then what you do is you leave
behind the worker the proletarian who
depends on his salary
and so you know there's
there's that uh give and take
and I'm not sure that uh they can uh
overcome the debt that is here to stay
and not only here to stay but here to
grow Okay so
debt is a problem and uh so we have what
uh growth is a problem
that is a problem salaries are a problem
and of course uh labor the fact
unemployment that's also a problem
okay and here we have uh
um India and looking at its population
there was an article so the country's
population has more than quadrupled
since independence from Colonial rules
75 years ago but in the past 60 years a
percentage of people age 60 and over in
Kerala town over there a region in India
has shut up from 51 5.1 to 16.5
everybody's becoming old some mother
that has to do with migration
immigration people young people leaving
but some of it also has to do with the
fact that you know kids are not having
kids okay uh they're just leaving and
not creating new people the Aging
population combined with the migration
of younger Generations means there will
be 30 uh be 35 people over 60 in the
state for every 100 working age people
by 2030. so the numbers are uh not
looking very great okay the state's
unique demographic is in India are due
to the declining what fertility and
increasing life expectancies
so the population pyramid is overturning
in India and here we have Africa which
is half the population of India okay all
of Africa the whole continent about half
the population of India and look at the
fertility rates you know uh you can see
that they used to have more children
before
and now it's coming down for all these
countries
and
um they think it's related to
contraception fact that a lot of women
are using contraception
um
I disagree I don't think it's uh got to
do with contraception specifically
it does help yeah of course uh that's
not the main reason what is the main
reason well here was an article it says
the world's Peak population may be
smaller than expected and uh it's
talking about Africa's slowing Baby Boom
remember Africa is the one everybody's
counting on to take the numbers up right
in population it says your demographers
would be more inclined to agree that
these fertility declines are real and
likely to continue if they could easily
identify their causes they don't know
the causes okay teasing out the
causality is tricky okay so what's the
problem well they think it's
contraception or a family planning or
girls education uh climate change okay
some propose that climate change is
causing this whole problem uh economists
in general think that poor families have
uh more children that's that's the
worldly wisdom out there and last but
not least the one that I propose is that
last one there and they just put it in
there like you know we saw it but we
don't pay too much attention to this is
there are often big Regional differences
fertility rates are much lower for urban
women who typically have 30 to 40
percent fewer children than those in the
countryside
yes urbanization that's what's killing
population okay people are moving from
the country to the cities there's this
transition going on that's the
underlying cause Okay the underlying
cause is that why what happens when you
come to the city you have different
economics different culture okay you
have density dependent birth rates
all these things that are caused by
urbanization the fact that we are many
in a small area in a small region and
people say well people can travel there
you know nobody's holding on to them
turns out that everybody's Tethered to
to the city for different reasons that's
where their livelihood is and whatever
and that's they can't work it out there
in the middle of the desert so everybody
goes to the cities
and the cities are growing and towns are
becoming cities uh villages are becoming
towns and so on you know populations are
growing in the cities that's where
that's where everybody's going when you
go to the cities uh you abandon the
country and a lot of the Agricultural
corporations buy the land they uh Mass
produce food
that later on gets you know sold to the
cities that's what it's working today
okay and so here you have uh what's
happened in the last few years
urbanization rate in Africa from 2000 to
2025. you can see how it's going up up
and up and you can see some of the
Cities there that have uh ballooned also
and that's actually what's happening you
know people are moving from the country
to the cities so a lot of these
countries by the way they're uh they're
empty people say oh they're so populated
no they're Nigeria is an empty country
it's got a lot of land believe me but
that's not where people are people are
always in the big cities in Lagos and
you know all the big cities are where
all these people are at
so people don't go out into the middle
of the desert and say I'm going to live
here no it doesn't work anywhere people
go in the country go from the towns to
the cities okay so yeah this is what's
happening
um
you have uh
another uh side to that which is density
dependence okay and here you see it
these are these are a list of animals
for which it's been verified that they
have density dependent birth rates uh
it's been measured okay uh people have
gone in there studied them and they made
a list of at least some verified animals
that when they reach a certain density
for a given plot of land or whatever
they stop having kids or their
um reproductive rate goes down as a
whole for the whole herd or whatever
they are right so yeah density dependent
and by the way humans are on the list we
are density dependent animals okay we
cannot avoid density dependence
it's been verified for humans as well
that's why we're growing asymptotically
as far as population is concerned not
because there's not enough land in the
world I mean just take Russia it's got
so much land out there it's an empty
country
and nobody lives over there on the other
side of the URLs everybody lives what in
Moscow Landing garage Salinger and so on
you know St Petersburg uh that's where
people go they live in the cities those
are the cities that are growing uh not
out there in the middle of nowhere
nobody goes out there
but uh you could change the uh the trend
by creating towns somehow okay
and uh yeah that's one of the things
that they should be working on I'm not
even sure that's going to help in this
day and age but yeah if they could
create towns new towns in the middle of
nowhere the government you know create
some kind of incentive for young people
to go there then you probably have an
explosion of population again I think
that's the only way to do it but it
would have to be you know at the point
of a gun you'd have to get people to get
down there I don't know find gold
and go as a minor or something like that
like in the 1849 the 49ers right
or Alaska go okay so this is what
density dependent birth rates conduces
to it's the overturning of the
population pyramid and eventually to
what to extension okay there is no uh S
curve the s-curve ends
in a straight down exponential decline
of humanity Okay so
yeah there is no smooth curve for for
the world population it's going to get
to a point
and it's going to continue growing maybe
slightly less and less and less
approaching zero but before that happens
uh the global economy I think will
collapse and then it's going to be
straight down that's why it's not going
to be a smooth uh curve that goes up and
down forever now it's just going to go
all the way down exponentially
okay let's move on to space time our
good old subject matter for the day what
is space time well let's begin at the
beginning uh we covered the following we
had uh space okay and we looked at
existence we looked at time in the last
couple weeks okay
uh space and existence are easy you know
they're um uh static Concepts they fit
in a single frame as you can see they're
the yellow uh uh bracket there uh they
fit in a single frame of the universal
movie
what's a universal movie well it's a
tool that's what it is the tool where we
have location only location a static
Concept in every single frame of that
film so it's like using God's camera
right and he takes a snapshot of the
entire unit he's outside the universe
right and
Saint Augustines so he takes a snapshot
of the universe right he gives you the
snapshot okay and so you can see every
atom in the universe every Star every
planet every Galaxy it's there but
steady in a static mode okay because
this location distance between all the
objects that's all you have in a single
frame okay so there you can at least
isolate all the static Concepts and
there's a couple of them there that we
use in physics object distance location
existence and we have also space right
it's a static concept
uh space is not a thing space is that
black stuff there what is that black
stuff well it's not a stuff what it is
is a synonym of nothing what is nothing
what's the opposite of something
something is that which has shape
nothing is that which doesn't have shade
see how easy it was there are antonyms
you can use those terms consistently now
on the other hand you have time
time is a dynamic concept and we
illustrate that by showing that you need
at least two frames of the movie that
the base bracket on the bottom so all
those Concepts there those are all
Dynamic Concepts a column dynamic
because they require at least two frames
of the universal movie
so that we have what we have space which
is a static concept and we have time
which is a dynamic concept
how do you merge them how do you put
them together
that that's the question it's like
putting together standing still and
moving
how do you do that
right and that's more or less the
situation that's going to be the the
trick
uh how do you how do you achieve that
and apparently uh you know we have
people here we have one fellow who uh
put a comment okay and he said the
following says existence isn't static we
are constantly moving through space even
if we're still sitting still
our brains are of Apes oh okay that
explains that okay maybe that's his
family there okay there's no reason for
us to understand the truly fundamental
nature of time only what is useful to
survive yeah I guess if you live in the
jungle I guess it doesn't matter where
you know how you define time right and
it's not important just survive right
talk to any real scientist and they'll
admit that limitations of these the
limitations of these Concepts okay that
means they they don't know how to define
them that's all it is I've watched many
of Brian Green's vids he's a down to
earth guy and knows that we don't know
squat about the universe
yeah Brian Greene I guess he's um
he's proud of him not knowing anything
and I don't know why this fellow
idolizes uh Brian Green because I mean
why does he follow him and he follow him
because he knows her because he doesn't
know if he doesn't know why why make him
to be such a hero
you know I mean staying it there you
know in the 19th century he had this uh
Know Nothing party in the United States
it lasted for a while and then it went
out and looks like these folks have
re-uh
uh restarted this uh party now it's
they're the no nothing party they know
nothing they're proud of it all right
but again why would anyone uh idolize a
fellow like Brian Green if he tells you
that he doesn't know anything okay
uh you would think it's the other way
around that you if you're looking for a
physicist or a scientist or whatever uh
you would look for someone who can
explain something and tell you something
but if the guy says oh by the way we
know nothing
oh great you know you're my hero
okay and uh here's another villain these
are the funny time is a tool to record
the temporal aspect of change
I like it because they come here you
know and they they boast like oh you
know nothing but let me tell you what
time is and he said a temporal aspect of
change you look up temporals as of a
relating to time
so that's that for that
yeah these people never learn how to
define terms they don't think uh
defining terms is important and so when
you criticize them on the basis of you
know their definitions they say oh
you're doing semantics Bill you're doing
word salad you know they dismiss that
because they don't like that their
definitions are torn apart so easily and
they are you know so yeah it's very
important to Define terms in physics
without that without what I call the
foundations of physics without a set of
definitions of the most important words
you're going to use to give a physical
interpretation you have absolutely
nothing you need to know words such as
object distance
location exist motion concept space
you know you need to know uh how to
define those terms then you can carry
out a
rational definition rational discussion
with someone but if you don't know what
a an object is especially you don't know
what existence means what do you mean by
exist does God exist Does God not exist
I mean
you know um then you can go on chasing
your tail forever in circles
so yeah you need to define words anyways
here we had in uh what was it 1911 I
think it was
um yup I know 1908. and this is
minkowsky and he said gentlemen the
concepts of time and space which I would
like to develop before you today have
grown on experimental physical grounds
in other words they did experiments
and they got these conclusions and they
say oh we discovered space time okay and
henceforth Space by itself and Time by
itself shall completely reduce to a mere
Shadow
it's the death of time and space
separately and only some sort of Union
of the two shall preserve Independence
so again how do you
um merge space and time when space is
static concept and time is dynamic and
of course when you go out there you
don't find the definition for the word
time especially okay nobody has a
definition to this day that you can sink
your teeth in they all eventually say
well by the way we don't we don't know
how to define time we don't know what it
is exactly but we use it anyways we use
it in our equations and we have the
space time where we merge time with
space you know they can do all those
things but they can't Define the word
time and of course they can't define
space they don't know what space is to
this day they say it's made out of
particles particles that pop in from
space from the vacuum from the void
right and so space is made out of
particles it's a thing then they say
it's infinite like the numbers and
others say no it's not infinix finite
and so we don't know if it's finite or
infinite if it's a thing or not
we have no idea I mean you know the
mathematicians they have no idea what
space is and so they're going to take
this unknown called space they're going
to merge it with an undefined term
called time
and they create a space time and they
say they proved it through experiments
okay
uh here we have uh good old ainee I
showed us the other day he took that
um
space time he started warping it saying
that that's uh gravity for you okay
you're a mass Bend space time okay and
that's what compels Mass to roll around
on other mass or around space time okay
so this is what they did they took this
concept space and time merged it and now
they're starting to warp it
okay think about that for a minute you
know it's like taking love and
intelligence merging them and saying
we're going to warp it now
yeah okay let's see let's see how you do
that
okay so uh what is actually space time
well
if you remember for those of you who
went to high school right you had a uh
what is called Cartesian coordinates you
have uh the X on the bottom and the Y on
the side right and so what you do you
use that to locate objects like you know
you want to locate the position of
something you take uh for example an
ordered pair you take a number on X it
could be a number six so you take six
steps along the X then and go five steps
upward on the Y and you end up at some
point six five and that's a location
there on that coordinate system okay
very simple stuff that they teach you in
high school okay what's happened here is
they've taken that
and that's what they turned into
space-time
okay and here's a graphic uh
representation of that that I want to
show you okay here it is you have the
Cartesian coordinates okay and you have
X on the bottom and Y on the side what
they did they turned this into this
space-time thingy
and then they started you know warping
it as well you know that's what they did
okay so what you have here is a
coordinate system that's all it is it's
a mathematical system which they turned
into a physical system okay they simply
went in there uh
you know turned it into this space-time
canvas uh fishnet whatever you want to
call it trampoline and then they put
some weights in it you know that's Mass
pushing it down
figuratively okay pushing it down and
that's what uh the cause of gravity is
okay so what you have is really a
Cartesian coordinate system that has
been turned into this physical thing
called space time okay it's a
mathematical concept
especially the time part
the the space I don't know about that
because again space belongs to physics
space is not something related to
numbers bases that black stuff out there
whatever that is and so you you have to
point to it if it's an object you got to
show what the what it looks like if it's
an object if you present it as an object
so you gotta show us the edges of space
and label whatever's you know outside of
it so that we can get an idea you know
what is encapsulating space that's if
space is an object a thing
and on the other hand uh if you say
space is a concept no problem that's
what we say here as well uh you have to
define it you have to define the word
space and we Define it as that which has
no shape
okay so it's not infinite it's not
finite because infinite and finite are
adjectives you can only apply these
adjectives to objects to things space is
not a thing space is the opposite of a
thing space is nothing that which has no
shape therefore it can't be eat neither
uh
infinite or finite okay
uh so that's our definition but whoever
gives the presentation you know whoever
thinks a space is an object has to first
point to space and label space and
whatever's encapsulating it that's the
way it works in science
okay uh we had uh the other day Mr um
Augustine here St Augustine and he
created the notion of the block Universe
which is again a synonym really of
space-time okay what did God do before
he created universe that's the question
he was trying to answer okay because
some people obviously asked him that
question and so he had this reasoning
process he said God is not Material God
is spirit that comes from the Bible
right God doesn't move okay God is right
because if God is a spirit God is a
concept and therefore doesn't move so so
far we're we're totally with him okay I
agree here with Augustine okay August
time I call him uh because he dealt so
much with time he says God is eternal
he's been there every always why because
he's in the present tense he doesn't
move he's just in present tense and that
is as Eternal As It Gets
God is outside the universe okay so the
universe is something that's outside of
God God is going to create this universe
he created it and says time began when
God made the universe in other words
time is inside the universe which is
exactly what space-time uh is what
general relativity says they say that
space and time are within that ball that
you see there that uh well that
flattened out ball there okay God is
outside God doesn't move God is really
Spirit not a a bearded guy like I put
there okay God is a spirit so he doesn't
move he can't move because he's a
concept okay so far so good how
something that is a concept created a
something that is an object I don't know
okay that's something you got to explain
the process there but other than that
we have God outside the universe God
doesn't move God is Spirit right he
creates this universe
right and it turns out this universe has
space and time within its borders
okay we call that the block Universe
also known as space time okay so let's
make sure we understand that okay so uh
general relativity did not come up with
that concept the concept of blocked
Universe it was all ready there from
Augustine in his confessions he uh his
book confessions about uh what was it
about 350 380 BC or something like that
A.D
um that's when he wrote it
I I think it was closer to the year 400
okay anyways he wrote that book
confessions you can look it up and here
we see good old um Brian Greene
and he's going to take uh the block
Universe which he Likens to a loaf of
bread he's going to slice uh pieces off
of it each one of those slices is what
time again and I discussed the other day
that you can't do that because time
requires at least two frames of the
universal movie so you cannot slice it
you cannot have a single slice a single
slice as Brian Green is showing there is
really location it is not time okay not
motion or look or uh time it's only
location distance objects space and all
static Concepts such as existence okay
okay
um
so here we have Mr Stephen Hawking what
does he have to say he's a guru or was a
guru until recently of space-time
and this is what he has to say in his
book his famous book A Brief History of
Time Einstein made the Revolutionary
suggestion that gravity is a consequence
of the fact that space-time is curved
space-time is cleared what do you mean
or what right and she says uh how can
that possibly be if space-time is a
concept what do you mean it's curved or
warped curved and warped are words that
relate to physical objects and good old
uh Stephen Hawking he's treating
space-time as a physical object and he's
not the only one as you can see up there
NASA okay uh they have a picture of this
they show this space-time canvas this
fishnet being warped by the Earth okay
by the mass of the earth as so they say
okay and the question is here
everybody's treating that as a real
physical entity because they are talking
about curved and warped concept called
space time
and so he continues he clarifies just in
case you didn't understand okay bodies
like the Earth are not made to move on
curved orbits by a force called Gravity
the mass of the Sun curves space-time in
such a way that although the Earth
follows a straight path in
four-dimensional space-time it appears
to us to move along a circular orbit in
three-dimensional space so uh the Earth
actually travels in a straight path
but that's out there in the
four-dimensional world you know
tesseracts and whatever here on Earth we
we poor little creatures we see it in us
going around in a circle uh because we
can only see up to three dimensions and
no more okay so the mass of the Sun
curves based them in such a way that
although the Earth straight path in 4D
space Hemet appears to move along a
circular path in three-dimensional space
okay in general relativity bodies always
follow straight lines in
four-dimensional space but they
nevertheless appear to us to move a long
curved path in our three-dimensional
space
he says that in his book here you have a
guy who you study at least 10 years at
the universe and he says this nonsense
okay not only does he create space and
time
both which are Concepts he treats them
as a physical object he warps them he
curves them
he's going to put the Earth there and
he's going to say well the reason it
goes around the Sun
um it actually goes in a straight line
in four-dimensional space but here in
our world we see it as circular movement
totally crazy I mean I don't know about
the four-dimensional I mean I haven't
drank the 10 beers that Hawking drank
you know maybe that's what made him see
these Visions all we see here is that
you know the earth goes around the Sun
in in a circle more or less right
and the question is why and they say
well the reason it goes around in
circles is this space time is curved in
other words time is curved and there's
this wall that's what they're showing
that's what they illustrate that's what
they explain there's this wall of time
that prevents the Earth from flying out
of the solar system
curved time
so you figure that out okay and just in
case uh you might say well Bill you
maybe you misunderstood
here's NASA okay NASA this is from their
page okay NASA's gravity probe a little
rocket they sent out there with uh some
gyroscopes and to test whether the
gyroscopes would drag space-time around
itself again treating it space-time as a
physical object okay
says gravity probe B Mission has
confirmed two key predictions derived
from Albert Einstein general relativity
right which the space shuttle was
designed this test okay the experiment
launched in 2004 used four Ultra precise
gyroscopes to measure the hypothesized
geodetic
um effect the warping of space and time
around a gravitational Body and Frame
dragging you know they're going to drag
space-time around right the amount of
spinning the amount a spinning object
pulls space and time with it as it
rotates it's pulling on on Time how do
you pull on time and drag it around
yourself
Jesus Christ what are these people
talking about and we spend money you
know uh taxes and so I'm paying to for
this whole thing okay gravity Pro be
determined it's already been proven
right both effects with unprecedented
Precision by pointing at a single star
etc etc
okay so what are they saying they're
they used gravity probe to drag
space-time around itself
it's dragging it's pulling on time
that's what they're telling you
these are people who have at least
10-year degrees phds in telling you this
nonsense this poppycock
that in a uh a gyroscope is pulling
space or time both space and time but
specifically time because I think that's
straightforward I mean how do you pull
on time how do you pull on a second
okay that's what they're saying okay and
someone uh explains also over there at
Nasa says time and space according to
Einstein theories of Relativity are
woven together they're woven someone I
guess God wove them together yeah used
maybe the Rope hypothesis the Rope to do
this forming a 4D fabric called
space-time you're talking about a fabric
what's a fabric they're talking about
you know some kind of um uh shirt maybe
a dress you know they're talking about
something okay the mass of Earth uh
dimples this fabric much like a heavy
person sitting in the middle of a
trampoline Okay so so I think you're
getting the hang of this uh it's not
that I'm coming up with all this these
people are telling you in your face that
there's something called space end time
you drag them around you can sit on it
and when you sit in it you push it
downwards
gravity says Einstein is simply the
motion of objects following the
curvaceous lines of the dimple if Earth
were stationary that would be the end of
the story but Earth is not stationary
our planet spins and the spin should
twist The dimple slightly pulling it
around into a four-dimensional swirl so
now the the Earth Twirls around it's
going to pull on space and or time right
this is what GPB went to space in 2004
to check put a spinning gyroscope into
orbit around the Earth where the spin
axis pointed towards some distant Star
as fixed reference point okay free from
external forces the gyroscopes axis
should continue pointing at the star
forever but if space is Twisted okay
space space nothing is Twisted okay the
direction of the gyroscopes axis would
drift over time by noting this change in
Direction relative to the star the
twists of space time could be measured
my dear God
you know uh when it comes to it I'd
rather go back to the old-time religion
than the new time really this stuff is
beyond me okay uh they're warping time
they're pulling on time they're sitting
on time weighing it down curving it and
that causes little balls like the Earth
to go around in circles forever that's
their explanation that's their physical
interpretation and of course when you
point that out to them and say well we
don't understand it either and by the
way you're you're bringing up a subject
that belongs in philosophy we just do
equations we don't do physical
interpretations
so why did they even try
why did they even attempt a physical
interpretation if it's not part of their
job description
or very simple because if they didn't
other math would be worthless
which it is and because all their math
is leading them to conclude something
about the universe that ain't so and
that is how it works and it doesn't work
the way relativity says with space-time
and time being warped it doesn't work
that way believe me okay so this
nonsense that they have that uh you can
warp time and that you can work space
which is nothing you know how do you do
that you know grab a piece of space and
show me how you work it very simple you
know
okay uh but he doesn't stop there
Hawking continues because he says look
look if space time is Warped right guess
what happens to light when it tries to
travel well here you have a zigzag uh of
light again the fact that space is
curved means that light no longer
appears to travel in straight lines in
space General royalty what predicts
we're going to talk about that today
with our
science credit right predicts that light
should be bent by gravitational fields
so there you see how it's warped okay
now he said it should be bent I don't
know how you can bend light when they
say it's made out of photons
you're going to best talk about deflect
and deflection you deflect a series of
photons not Bend what are you bending
here are you bending a photon
I mean what do they tell you they don't
even have their language correct okay
but yeah is that how light travels in
like a curve around the Sun and then
around the earth and so on well I don't
think so you know light always travels
straight
to linearly it's called
okay and uh what are some of the other
conclusions that Mr Hawking comes up
with he says before 1915 space and time
were thought of as fixed arena in which
events took place what which was not
affected by what happened in it bodies
moved forces attracted and repelled but
time and space simply continued
unaffected it was natural to think that
space and time went on forever
space and time are now wet Dynamic
quantities when a body moves or a force
acts it affects the curvature of space
and time meaning that they move and in
turn the structure of space-time affects
the way in which bodies move and forces
act
this was saying that space and time move
okay so it's not only bodies that move
but space and time move and I I like to
uh you know ask his bartender to give me
the same stuff he had
laughs
Jesus Christ okay and then he says the
father says the old idea of an
essentially and changing universe that
could have existed and could continue to
exist forever was replaced by the notion
of a dynamic expanding universe meaning
you know what's his expanding space
right and I guess time as well because
time is expanding right that seemed to
have begun a finite time ago and that
might end up finding time in the future
the Revolution was to be the starting
point for my work in theoretical physics
okay great what did you find out Roger
Penrose and I showed that Einstein's
general theory of relativity implied
that the Universe must have a beginning
okay so there's the beginning a little
explosion there called The Big Bang and
from there we have this bottle that or I
guess the glass
uh sometimes I put some beer in it okay
um I guess it fell on its side but that
is your space time there there's the
time is going rightwards and I guess
space
um is is in inside each one of those
frames each side inside each one of
those uh cross sections or slices as
Brian Green uh Illustrated you slice
them apart okay
okay so what should we conclude from all
this well this is what space time is it
started out as a coordinate system okay
what they did was replace uh with with
space and space uh the three dimensions
of space are there in a single axis and
then they arbitrarily replace the axis
of height with time okay so we have
space on x-axis time on the y-axis from
there they kind of turn that into space
time
and then they started warping it so what
are they warping they're warping this
concept this coordinate system created
or
originated by uh Rene Descartes okay
17th century okay so this is what it's
all about what you're warping is this
concept
and that's what these people deal with
every day they talk about space time and
then of course they're going to put it
in there black holes and wormholes and
dark matter and dark energy and they're
going to fit it in that space time it's
part of that space time part of it is
these other things that they've created
over time right
so we have space and time uh coordinate
system that's been warped and you're
going to be putting these other entities
which are mathematical Concepts again
they're going to fit them in there to
explain basically gravitational
phenomena that's that's the point of it
all
okay so why doesn't the Earth fly out of
the solar system according to general
relativity because of space-time you
have warp time there's this wall
of a warped canvas so to speak a warp
fishnet and it's at warpage that creates
a wall so to speak that prevents the
Earth from flying out of the solar
system
uh the funny part is that you know the
Earth is not allowed to go
outwards but you know we're at the edge
of the Earth there and I don't feel
squashed by this wall of time
so I don't know why the wall of time
does not squash us
okay that's something that they would
have to explain because it can stop the
Earth right because the Earth is banging
up against the wall right it's a sliding
or rolling along this wall but we're at
the edge of the Earth and we don't get
squashed
so I don't know you you figure that out
how it is that the Earth can roll around
Time Warp time
it it work time is strong enough to
prevent the Earth from flying out but
it's not strong enough to squash you
against the the ground of the Earth
food for thought
okay let's move on to our science critic
and he had to say something about
predictions and I guess uh he doesn't
understand the difference between a
description and an explanation
and so he tried to con his way is saying
look if we know what happened in the
past we can predict the future
totally irrelevant
a prediction only deals with the future
and if you just make a statement of
what's going to happen in the future all
you did was utter a description that's
all you did so far if you can explain
why
it's going to
happen you're talking about the past
you're talking about your experience he
still doesn't understand that let's see
if some of you at least can understand
what the difference is okay let me put
them on here here he goes listen
carefully
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal include
a prediction has solely to do with the
future
a prediction without more it's just a
description
if you can explain why the prediction is
going to materialize you are no longer
predicting
you are now talking about the past
if you want to work out what's going to
happen a good idea to do that is to work
out what has happened by paying
attention to what has happened I can
then work out what's going to happen
like if I keep on dropping an object and
keeps on Falling Towards the ground then
I can assume that if I keep on dropping
the object it's going to keep on
dropping towards the ground
so I guess he he doesn't understand he
cannot talk about explanations of the
future explanation belongs exclusively
to the past and has to do with our
experience
so here's uh my assessment okay
uh what has happened is the past
okay straightforward experience is also
the Past prediction on the other hand is
only related to the Future prediction is
only about the future prediction based
on experience is irrelevant okay we
don't care if you guessed it if you had
experience with it you had a bad dream
we don't we don't care it doesn't matter
when you make a prediction or you say
this is what's going to happen so far
all you made is a statement so far all
you did is describe what's going to
happen
prediction something is going to happen
Okay straightforward okay that's just a
description
uh prediction is a hundred percent
description that's all you said so far
something is going to happen it's just a
description you haven't said why
and you better not say why because as
soon as you say why it means you're
drawing on your experience the why part
has nothing to do with prediction the
why part has only to do with the past
with explanation okay and because these
people get so confused between
explanations and descriptions you have
the mathematicians predicting the past
all the time in fact here uh here are
three papers that I just pulled out of
the hat out there okay one says
predicting the initial conditions of the
universe using deep learning
universe how do you predict the past I
mean Jesus angular momentum Evolution
can be predicted from cosmological
initial conditions
and enough as the uncaused beginning of
the universe the prediction of a
space-time singularity in our past
so all these people end up predicting
the past why because because again they
confuse descriptions with explanations a
uh a prediction is only a description
so as long as you keep it there you're
okay now you can describe things that
you see in front of you or describe
things in the past as well describe it's
not a problem the problem is prediction
is only a description
but not all descriptions are predictions
okay so let's make sure we got that
right prediction is only about the
future prediction is only a description
up to that point it's a statement that's
all it is that something's going to
happen
if you can say why is going to happen
how you got that conclusion was it a
lucky guess did you have a bad dream we
don't care the point is if you can
explain why now you're drying on your
experience and that's only the past
okay so what happens is people are
predicting the past they end up
predicting you know how the universe
started or the initial conditions of the
universe or whatever
that's not a prediction okay what you're
doing is explaining and turning that
into a prediction
okay you're they're they're kind of
reverse engineering it they're saying
well you know if we take all these stars
and pull them all the way together you
know yesterday closer and closer
together we end up with the initial
conditions of the universe and this is
what should have happened if my
calculations are correct that's not a
prediction okay they're trying to
explain the origin of the universe which
is nonsense anyways but aside from that
you're explaining a theory of how the
universe came to be you're not
predicting anything but they use the
word prediction line because it's so you
know it's important in mathematics to
say oh I can predict oh then you got a
good crystal ball here's your Noble or
your Templeton Prize or whatever
so that's the way it works
okay uh let's look at some of the
questions that people raised since last
time fellow says how does electricity
actually generated in a living being is
it the heart that generates electricity
but what then drives the heart if not
electricity
well you know first uh this is our uh
version of electricity okay uh
uh atoms are or you could say even
molecules are bound together physically
bound together uh
uh you know if you look at the um
balloons that are the electrons all
these balloons merge okay they're not
little electron beads that orbit what
we're saying is they are balloons that
encapsulate the atom it's the surface of
the atom it's a membrane it's a balloon
and when these balloons merge okay they
form these long strings when they uh I
call them serpentines and when they uh
spin at Great velocity that's what we
call uh electricity what they swing
around are the threads that connect them
and that form part of their electron
shells and that's what we call magnetism
okay a field as they call it in
mathematics okay so this is our version
of electricity so the phones just wants
to know you know how do I relate this to
the human body
and no I don't think uh that the
um electricity starts at the heart
I think electricity is everywhere
and you can almost prove this to
yourself if you want if you want to do a
little experiment you know
and remember experiments are for proof
they belong to religion and just get you
to believe something it has nothing to
do with Theory okay but uh pinch your
toe
and you'll feel it in instantly
where are you feeling it or you're
feeling it in your brain really
and you say well I feel it in my toe
you feel it down there right but see if
um if you were quadriplegic
right and I pinch your toe you probably
wouldn't feel it more than likely you
won't feel it
and you say well why can't you feel it
I'm pinching your toe I mean hurting
it's bleeding and you still can't feel
it
and yeah because you have your some
disconnection somewhere in your body
that prevents you the signal from going
to your brain
okay so yeah all that's tied in in a
single connection
okay everything's tied in there and I'm
saying that you know and you have these
nerves which are cells and you have
between them and synapsis and the
synapsis which is this empty region that
they never were able to figure out
because it's an invisible no man's land
in there I'm saying that there you have
uh material you have either the ropes
connecting that or some atoms or
whatever but there's something there and
that carries the signal physically all
the way to your brain if you were to
sever you know that region like in the
case of a quadriplegic that's got some
disconnection there then yeah you won't
you won't have the signal travel all the
way to your brain and you can pitch his
toe and he won't feel anything
okay so I uh all I'm saying is I don't
think it starts in the heart I think
electricity and magnetism are all over
our body as well as obviously chemical
reactions of different kinds right so
you know I can't tell you uh where it
starts I don't think it starts anywhere
I think it's simply across the board all
your nerves are elect chemical
electrical signals and I think magnetism
is involved in that process as well
and other than that you know I don't
think I can give you more information
that's really for doctors and people who
do research on the body you know I don't
I don't spec I don't specialize in
bodies except females bodies that do not
specialize in okay but anyways here we
have Saint Paul says if the mechanism of
temperature is the length of links in a
row how does that apply to
stratification of distillates
um uh does the complexity of the
molecules and thus the number of ropes
acting upon them determine specific
gravity okay so let's get the terms
first in here what's uh distillation uh
here you have an example okay fractional
distillation okay and uh you have
different temperatures uh for oil and
you get different products out of each
one of those okay and each one has a
different specific gravity okay so
that's in a nutshell okay what uh
distillation is okay let's take this out
and here you have a definition of
specific gravity
ah what did I do with it
give me a second here on the other side
sometimes it does that the term specific
gravity is used to define the weight or
density of a liquid as compared to the
density of an equal volume of water at a
specified temperature so different
temperatures will vary also the density
okay and that should be straightforward
for people to understand the temperature
used for measurement is usually 39
Fahrenheit 40 degrees okay because this
temperature allows water to assume its
maximum density okay so they look at
Water's maximum density and they Peg all
the values of all the other uh gases and
liquids Etc to that value okay in the
metric system water has a density of one
gram per milliliter so density in
specific gravity are numerically equal
okay which is a good uh Benchmark okay
if the liquid you are comparing has a uh
specific gravity lower than one gram per
milliliter it will float on water
otherwise it will sink okay and there
you see an example okay they take that
acid mix it with water and now it's got
a different specific gravity okay so
this is the this is the question that
he's actually saying how does that
relate to ropes
okay so let me show you uh first an
example maybe we can get
that notion across with an example
better than anything else here we have
the density of hydrogen peroxide okay I
use that quite a bit in the
semiconductor industry we had a lot of
hydrogen peroxide around and you can see
how that density changes with
temperature okay so at uh close to uh
low low temperatures you can see that it
approaches the density of water but as
it goes as the temperature rises then
that temperature the density then
changes okay and the question is why is
that so how how is because density is
the specific gravity essentially okay
that's a measure of specific gravity and
here um here's an illustration of this
that will maybe put it in the right
perspective okay here you have water the
water molecule this is just uh
you know a drawing of how the water
molecule appears to be you have this
oxygen big oxygen right atom element and
you have two tiny hydrogens okay and
what if we were to now turn that into
hydrogen peroxide well we would have to
add another oxygen to that molecule okay
so we have we would have two oxygens and
two hydrogens whereas water has only one
oxygen two hydrogens but remember oxygen
is
um
element number eight okay that means
it's got eight electrons it's got eight
Balloons under uh under the Rope model
this is what it looks like more or less
okay that's more or less what oxygen
looks like okay you have the P orbitals
and the two s orbitals the circular ones
are the S S1 and S2 and the others are
the P orbitals okay so this would be if
you had God's eyes this is what the
oxygen atom the element known as oxygen
looks like okay and yeah it's not a
little bead that goes around which is
the where the quantum mechanics uh
version of the atom they say the
electron is a little bead that goes
around those balloons that's in that
region you can find it there they're
concerned about finding it not about
what it looks like and turns out there
is no little bead called the electron
going around what you have really is
balloons but imagine each one of those
balloons has at least one rope to every
atom in the universe you have to look at
each one of those balloons as a hydrogen
atom so the oxygen molecule is made up
of eight uh electrons or eight hydrogen
atoms you could say right it's got uh
eight protons and eight electrons
and it's this uh thing that you see
there that
um is going to be added to the H2O to
the water module to build hydrogen
peroxide Double H double O okay so you
can see that it's going to tend to
increase
uh the specific gravity of uh the water
of the water molecule okay so the water
molecule would be this and the other one
with the extra oxygen you're adding
eight more hydrogen atoms so to speak to
your molecule to your water molecule and
so you're creating a uh a heavier
molecule essentially okay at different
temperatures of course it's going to
have a different density if you have
many of these molecules in there but the
point here is that each one of those
balloons carries one rope
to every atom in the universe to every
hydrogen atom in the universe that means
that if you have a carbon atom right uh
element uh number 14 right then uh how
many uh ropes will you have will you
have a little more than oxygen okay
that's what you're going to have and it
depends on how many hydrogen atoms you
are required are putting into an atom
right to an element a chemical element
each one of those is going to have a
rope to every atom in the universe
including two other uh balloons within
that atom
okay so uh yeah it's gonna affect your
specific gravity in that sense Okay so I
hope you get a sense of it uh through
the illustrations of what I'm trying to
say here I'm saying that for every
hydrogen atom in the universe you're
going to have one rope so the more
elements the the more the heavier the
element the more hydrogen atoms you
could say are made into that element for
example in the case of uranium you have
92 hydrogen atoms in one atom in one
element okay they're merged in different
ways and I've talked about that in the
past essentially the membranes blend
into each other and they form these
weird shapes there you know it's like
tying balloons you know and you make all
these many balloons around it and
imagine uranium 92 protons 92 electrons
92 balloons that's 92 hydrogen atoms
essentially okay not to mention the
neutrons which are surpassing you have
235 238 neutrons in that atom okay but
the point is that for every balloon you
have one rope okay and that of course
makes the atom not only that element not
only heavier but if it's mixed with some
other liquid or whatever it's going to
increase the density of that liquid
meaning the specific gravity okay okay
uh process uh time dilation is happening
isn't belief hypothesis or Theory it's a
fact aha time dilation is a fact the G
for GPS to function correctly time
dilation must be adjusted for
okay and so okay what is this uh what is
time it's a system of sequential
relations duration you look at duration
the length of time synonym they go back
to time what is dilate to make wider or
larger cause to expand to spread out
so with uh this is what I was saying
that time dilation is happening and
otherwise uh clocks wouldn't work or
whatever GPS wouldn't work and yeah I
guess time is expanding
how do you expand time yes it's a
concept it's a undefined concept but
he's going to expand it
if it's a concept I mean you're not
talking about a physical object you can
say a balloon expands yeah uh you can
say the bubble gum you know you blow it
and make this big bubble right
but to say that time expands how do you
do that does intelligence expand does
love expand
well maybe he would say yeah
yeah okay uh yeah you need to Define
time before you can uh say it's anything
about like time dilation or whatever
dilation by the way is a word that
belongs exclusively to physics has
nothing to do with math so can't even be
borrowed okay again dilation means you
make it wider you make it bigger and you
can't make uh numbers bigger
meaning fatter taller yeah more volume
okay it doesn't it's not applicable to
numbers or anything in math
okay same fellow says technology is into
massive exponential growth
where
I'm saying technology was over
especially when they invented the
computer
uh that was the last time we had
technology since then we have some
gadgets that are being invented you
could say you know but they're not
critical I mean the critical inventions
happen in the and at the end of the 19th
century beginning of the 20th and that
was you know telephone the car the
airplane those were the inventions okay
after that we had a few more you know
all the way up to uh you could say uh
the computer the chip and then later the
computer and after that uh all we did
was put them all together you know what
is a cell phone well a cell phone's not
an invention it's a uh it's putting
together several invention uh you put a
typewriter you put a radio you put a TV
you put a computer you put a telephone
you put them all together and you have a
cell phone so a cell phone is just a
repackaging of all those inventions in
one uh apparatus in one device that's
all it is so we haven't had any
inventions real invent since
groundbreaking inventions enter we won't
have any uh I mean some people are
expecting this Singularity like you have
uh Kurzweil one of the fellows out there
who vouches who are the technological
singularity the point at which the
computers and the robots out there will
invent more things than human can
possibly invent on their own and they
will take off and invent gazillions of
technology that we cannot even imagine
what can I say if you cannot imagine it
it will never happen because we are
supposed to imagine
technology you know like uh you had uh
Jules Verne the end of the 19th century
he was suggesting that uh you know we
could fly with a balloon around the
earth or go to the Moon well people say
well you're crazy we can't go to the
moon it's impossible
and uh Flat Earth or still say that
but uh some people said okay uh let's
see if we can get to the moon and in the
60s at the end of the 60s 68 right
um a man went to the moon Armstrong
stepped on the moon right some people
say he didn't okay that's fine but um we
went to the moon we had rockets at least
that can go out there and it was an
invention that uh Jules Verne already
had in the 19th century for him it was
um you know science fiction
you know it was just wishful thinking
but then it became a reality and that's
just one example you don't have to take
it to the moon you can get with the
airplane you can talk about the
telephone you know at some point people
say hey it'd be nice if I could talk to
this person in New York I'm in L.A you
know and eventually this came to be you
know first the they had the uh Telegraph
then it went into uh the telephone and
so on and so you know what was the idea
existed already it was there it was in
people's minds and eventually it came
true but you have to have the idea
before you can invent it before you work
on it and today we have no new ideas for
anything groundbreaking I mean what are
we going to invent the uh how to travel
through the fourth dimension you know
with some devices is that what is ahead
of us what invention can you imagine
that we need
see we need stoves to cook our food some
people don't even need that they just go
to McDonald's and they have their stove
over there you need a fridge to you know
make your beer can go cold you know and
uh you need bed to sleep on you need
pillows to put your head on and so on
chairs to sit on tables to eat on and so
on those are inventions that we need
you know we you could say we need them
we you know we can't really do without
them or we use them every day
what invention can you even imagine
forget about developing and just imagine
your wildest imagination right give me
an invention
that we need that if you invent it it
will put millions of people billions
hopefully to work in the manufacturing
industry
why do you think we have no
manufacturing today because there have
been no new inventions and because
whatever inventions we had and we modify
here we make it blue instead of red
right uh we put it on the assembly line
we have uh some robots and some people
working on that and all the rest of
people they don't need they say go go
home and all those people work in
services
so yeah inventions
had to do with the age of manufacturing
which is now over it died okay bury it
okay
right and uh so we will not be inventing
any more uh gadgets that will at least
put people to work which is where we
would need them right uh creating jobs
and
um also gadgets that we need I mean what
is it that we really need that we don't
have that we absolutely need and I'm not
talking about games okay that's that's
not an adventure
we'll see you next week bye bye